[Music]
and this is book TV on c-span 2 and
today we are live from the Savannah Book
Festival in Georgia now in its 10th year
the festival is host to several authors
and events throughout downtown Savannah
and book TV is live all day inside one
of the larger venues Trinity United
Methodist Church from now until about
4:00 p.m. Eastern
you'll hear from several authors
including former CIA officer William
Doherty Fox Business News 'as Gerri
Willis journalist dance later and more
you'll also have the chance to speak
with several of the authors as well now
we're going to kick off our coverage in
Savannah with John Tammany he's the
author of a new book who needs the Fed
what Taylor Swift uber and robots
tell us about money credit and why we
should abolish America's central bank
this is live coverage from the Savannah
Book Festival in Georgia starting now
good morning book lovers hopefully
everything's working my name is Linda
Huntoon and I'm delighted to welcome you
to the 10th annual Savannah Book
Festival presented by Georgia Power and
the Sheehan Family Foundation we are
blessed to host such as such celebrated
authors in the Trinity United Methodist
Church today which has been made
possible by the generosity of curd and
Libba Anderson we'd like to extend
special things to our literati members
and individual donors who have made and
continue to make Saturday's festival
free before I get started there's the
traditional caveat immediately following
this presentation John Hanley will be
signing festival purchase copies of his
book in Telfair Square his is slightly
different today because he has a short
interview with c-span immediately follow
so that gives you time to get to the
tent before him we have a new policy
this year if you're planning for the
next author presentation to stay here
please move forward so that the venue
empties and the ushers can determine how
many seats they have for people coming
in please please please take this moment
to turn off your cell phones and we also
ask that you not use flash photography
and for the question and answer portion
this year we are passing microphones so
there's no lining up in the center aisle
or any of the some of the things we've
done in the years past there are lots of
people around with microphones and mr.
Cammy is happy to take questions
John Candy is with us today courtesy of
hall and letting McAdams and Barbara
Paul he is a senior fellow at Reason
Foundation a senior economic advisor to
toreador research and trading and an
editor of real clear market.com rzm mr.
Kamini frequently writes about the
securities market along with tax trade
and monetary policy issues that impact
those markets for a variety of
publications including the Wall Street
Journal investor's business daily
Financial Times National Review and
London's Daily Telegraph's
please give a warm Savannah welcome to
John Pam Lee
Linda thank you very much for the
gracious introduction and thank you to
all of you for being here today it's a
passionate book people like you that
make it possible for me to get to do
what I love and so I can't stress my
gratitude enough also want to thank the
Savannah Book Festival for including me
as I look out at the other authors and
the other books being featured this
weekend I can't believe I'm in such good
company these are authors whom I've read
for years I'm kind of clicking my heels
up here that I get to be part of this
and so I want to thank the excellent
festival Kim bak iya swin for all the
work she did to make it possible for me
to be here I'd like to add to that Letty
McAdams
it's not in a literal sense but I
believe she moved mountains to get me in
the position to be here today and so I'm
forever in Letty's debt and also to her
husband Hall who's in the audience today
they're quite simply would not be a book
called who needs the Fed if not for Hall
what Hall knows about banking and credit
could fill many many thick books in over
the last thirteen years he's taught me
enormous amounts he's been so patient in
discussions in person by email over the
phone about these issues and if I had
not discussed all this with Hall and
learned so much from him there never
would have been a reason to write who
needs the Fed in the first place and so
big thanks to Hall before I get into the
book I'll talk a little bit about my
background I was actually born in
Charleston South Carolina so not too far
from here my dad was in the nuclear Navy
he served under the great Admiral Hyman
rickover once he got out of the Navy we
lived in Dallas in Atlanta then we moved
to Boston for two years that he could go
to business school and then we moved out
to Los Angeles and I grew up in Pasadena
California it was probably during grade
school that I discovered not knowing at
the time what I would eventually be
doing in terms of writing about
economics and economic policy there were
these little children's books in grade
school about
residents called meet Thomas Jefferson
meet Ben Franklin meet George Washington
and I would read them over and over
again and I would kind of be off to the
side in class reading about these
reading these books and I went to my
parents one night and I said I'm worried
that I'm in trouble at school I'm not
participating in the other things and so
my parents went to the teacher and she
mhm teacher said no we're thrilled but
he's interested in these books please
have them continue and so it was
probably signaled something ahead for
college I went to the University of
Texas and majored in political science
but not for any good reason it's just it
seemed like the most interesting major
at the time I can't say I learned a
whole lot one way or the other I think
most kids in school that's generally
what they do their focuses are elsewhere
after college I worked in sales for four
years and then went to Vanderbilt
Owen Graduate School of Management to
get my MBA
now while at Vanderbilt I decided to go
the normal route it was a booming bull
market in the late 90s so I thought okay
I'll get into this into equities just
like everyone else and I took a job at
Goldman Sachs and that's where what
began a future that's what that's where
my future career took shape while other
people were on the trading floor
passionate about equities I would look
around and watch CNBC on the different
screens and my focus was on the ekend
the economists talking about the economy
that's what that's what really had my
interest and what intrigued me the most
is there was this constant stream of
commentary at the time in the late 90s
saying that if the economy grew too much
as in people prospered too much if too
many people were working and creating
companies that there was a negative
downside that it would cause inflation
and I thought wait a second I grew up in
the 1970s I know inflation is it's a
devaluation of the dollar it's when the
Treasury drinks the value of the dollar
and I thought inflation is something
that occurs exclusive
of economic growth when economies are
growing investment surges and so the
prices of everything dropped and so I
had looked throughout history I
remembered the first mobile phone and in
the night in the early 80s Motorola put
it out
brick sized a half-hour of battery life
if you want to make a call from Savannah
to Atlanta is going to cost you a
fortune and roaming charges and I
thought well nowadays you can get mobile
phones for a fraction of the price and
then I knew from history that the first
mainframe computer was created by IBM in
the 1960s it cost over a million dollars
even by the late 90s you could get a
pretty good computer for a few thousand
nowadays we see we can get them for a
few hundred dollars but I thought that's
another example of the persistent drop
in the price of everything
thanks to investment everything I looked
rejected the common view of economics
from economists that somehow growth was
a problem that the sense that the Fed
and central banks had to plan it to make
sure that we didn't prosper enough and
so I wasn't allowed to do this goldman
sachs was full of immensely and talented
people and they were very specific that
you did your job that you didn't go
outside what you're doing but i secretly
started writing for clients commentary
saying that what you're hearing on CNBC
what you're reading in the newspapers is
belied by basic economic history and
common sense and so I started thinking
this is what I really want to do and
then by 2001 the stock market started to
dive what people pejoratively referred
to as the internet bubble effectively
popped now what I would say about that
is I don't think there's such thing as a
bubble that run-up in Internet stocks
was a beautiful thing it was a sign of
economic progress as was the decline of
those Internet companies it's when
economies are fit when there's lots of
failure in the economy that you know an
economy is progressing you need that
constant experimentation to get you into
a better place and so people looked at
that period as a negative but I looked
at it as a time and
it's the the the world and the u.s.
economy were utterly transformed by
advances that we could not live without
today now the downside to this big big
drop in equity prices particularly in
the internet economy was that suddenly
Goldman Sachs wasn't as interested in my
services as they had been a few years
ago and I'll say that was rather
devastating at the time you wonder you
start to question yourself you start to
question what kind of person you are
can I ever succeed again am I am I
doomed for failure but in fact it was
the best thing that ever happened to me
because it I'd already caught the bug I
thought I want to be commenting on the
economy about this I'll stress upfront
I'm not an economist and I wear that
lack of a PhD with pride I'm not a
journalist either but I thought I have
got to write about this it would pain me
to not be in the field of commentary in
these subjects and so the negative about
Goldman Sachs ultimately forced me to
figure out what I really wanted to do
and ultimately I moved to Washington DC
not as an economist or as a writer about
economics but as a fundraiser for the
Cato Institute my plan was to pay the
bills working during the day meeting
donors that was how I was going to pay
the bills so that I could write at night
and on weekends and that's how I met
Hall McAdams and I met people like Hall
who utterly transformed how I viewed the
world and made it even made me even more
determined to become an economic
commentator and gradually I did I will
go claim or Horatio Alger story or
anything like that but my initial online
columns that was the other beauty of the
internet boom as it made it possible for
someone like me to have a voice whereas
before I couldn't have had one so I
began as a writer from Washington DC no
one that no one wanted to have an
association with someone like me but
gradually I developed a reputation and
my reputation was one of basically
working against or contradicting the
conventional wisdom about economics
I felt the economics profession had lost
its way that had become about charts and
formulas and percentages rather than a
beautiful story of human action and I
thought people don't dislike economics
they just dislike how it's been
explained to them and my argument was
that if people could see the beautiful
world around them if they could
understand sports movies television
famous people and businesses they would
understand all that they would ever need
to know about economics and so that has
been my style of writing for all this
time and so my first book popular
economics which all of you should buy
several copies have later today was a
book that explained economic growth
through movies and sports and television
it got rid of all the graphs that had
wrecked what is really informative and
essential and that's the and and who
needs the fed which is the book I'm
talking about today is another example I
explained central banking and credit and
money through things that people can
understand and that's been my goal
throughout all this is that economics is
fun but people have taken the fun out of
it and it led to the book who needs the
fed now about who needs the fed what I
want to stress upfront is please don't
be fooled by the title and recover this
is a very optimistic book this is a book
that argues the Fed was never nearly as
powerful or in it or influential as is
commonly assumed and even better that
market forces are rapidly rendering the
Fed irrelevant right before our eyes
what can't be stressed about enough
about the Fed is that it doesn't have
any resources it can't increase credit
it cannot shrink credit the Fed can only
miss allocate the credit that we've
already created in the real economy the
Fed is large not because of the talented
people there it doesn't it's not active
in the markets because the people there
have a specific skill that the rest of
that central bankers around the world
don't have let's remember there are
central banks in Nigeria Cayman Islands
Barbados
Bahamas central banks are everywhere we
have a large one simply because the
American people are the most
economically productive people on earth
the feds swagger is not its own and
that's the broad point of my book that
when we talk about the Fed we're
misunderstanding it doesn't have the
credit it can't increase it the Fed can
only miss allocate the resources we've
already created and the argument I make
in the book is that we've vastly
overstate just how much the Fed miss
allocates it's just not that important
but I'm a big believer in market forces
and market signals I think that they're
full of information and in the same way
I think the electorate is full of
information there is lots of skepticism
right now in the world about our central
bank and I think there's some skepticism
based on one on a misperception and two
based on a very real understanding that
the world the Fed lives in is not
defined by reality
now the misperception is rooted in the
idea popularized by economists
politicians and pundits that money and
credit are one in the same but in fact
money and credit couldn't be more
different
if they were the same Haiti and Honduras
would have every bit as much credit
flowing through their economies as we do
in the United States I would add that
that would mean that counterfeiting
would not only be legal but he'd be
broadly encouraged in fact credit is
real economic resources to paraphrase
Ludwig von Mises when you borrow dollars
you're not borrowing dollars you're
borrowing access to computers trucks
tractors desks chairs buildings most of
all labor
we are the credit in the economy we are
the producers of the resources that when
people seek to borrow dollars they're
trying to attain the Fed has no private
stash of resources over here that it can
release into the economy we are the
creators of it now the frustration with
the Fed is somewhat separate people read
in the meat they watch peep the pundits
on TV they read in newspapers will the
Fed ease
the Fed tightened credit will the Fed
keep money easy at 0% and I think the
electorate properly looks at that and
says something's wrong with this picture
that doesn't reflect the reality that we
know Apple computers the most valuable
company in the world yet even it pays 3
percent to borrow anyone who's ever
started a small business or owned a
small business knows that to attain
credit it cost quite a bit more than 0%
it's much higher than 3% higher and
higher all the time and that's the broad
point of the first part of my book is
that while the feds over here decree
easy access to credit and easy money and
it's infinite unwisdom
in the real economy we act as though the
Fed doesn't exist and that's a very
positive statement about where we are
thinking about Hollywood Brian Grazer is
easily the most talented movie producer
in the history of the industry we're
talking about splash Parenthood a
beautiful mind
Apollo 13 talking about television shows
like empire 24 and Arrested Development
but his Grey's are freely acknowledges
his attempts to attain credit to fund
his movie and TV ideas fail 90% of the
time for this person with a near-perfect
track record
Hollywood as he puts it is the land of
know what about Silicon Valley it's
commonly assumed that if you've got a
startup idea out in the valley that
money sources will beat a path to your
door trying to invest with you but as
evidenced by all the billionaire venture
capitalists out the Silicon Valley we
know that credit is incredibly expensive
out there if you want to fund your
startup idea you'll first give up a big
portion of your business to a venture
capitalist and then you'll give up even
more of it in the form of stock options
to lure potential employees what about
Investment Banking one of the things
that offends me most in modern times is
how medium members have made Wall Street
a pejorative and it created the
perception that investment bankers are
somehow bad people I can't think of a
more important profession
an investment banking and one of the
reasons they're paid so well
has to do with the basic truth that in
the real economy the price of credit is
very expensive it's one thing to come up
with an idea for it for a business or
come up with an idea to expand your
business but it's quite another thing to
obtain the resources the credit
necessary to build on your vision and so
investment bankers are paid very well
properly so because they can do for
businesses what businesses can't do for
themselves many of you remember the name
Michael Milken the media in a similar
way demonized him he spent time in
prison for charges that had never been
prosecuted on anyone before I would
argue that michael milken's one of the
greatest capitalists who ever lived and
his insight back in the 1960s and 70s
was that unless you were the bluest of
blue chip businesses you were largely
shut out of the credit markets the
traditional banks did not regard you as
a reasonable credit risk and some milk
ins genius hid the source of his fortune
was the high-yield bond it was his way
of finding more expensive credit for
really promising businesses Time Warner
CNN Golden Nugget hotels ballistas long
of the great businesses that he attained
credit for and the broad point is
Milken's fortune was a function of the
fact that while the feds often
never-never-land to cream easy credit he
found it for very difficult credit
sources unless you're a blue chip it's
very hard to attain credit in the real
economy all of which brings us to our
45th president Donald Trump I like to
sell books and so I like to have stories
about people who are famous I feel like
that will drive more people to buy it as
all of you should and so thinking about
Donald Trump and let me stress that this
is not a political statement many of you
remember that he reached his height as a
real estate mogul back in the 1980s
that's when he was viewed as the
developer who could do no wrong the man
who had the vision for what the future
of tall buildings would be now what's
interesting about Trump is that as early
as nineteen nine
he was already viewed as a very major
credit risk by US banks in 1990 I tell
the story the book you flew out to Los
Angeles to visit with security Pacific
Bank which at the time was the fifth
largest US bank he wanted to borrow 50
million dollars in order to fund the
revitalization of the Ambassador Hotel
as you can imagine from modern times
Trump arrived at this meeting full of
confidence and swagger about his amazing
balance sheet of assets full of some of
the best properties on earth and network
that were easily highly liquid he was
the best lending option you had out
there why wouldn't you probably should
give me a hundred million dollars well
the bankers had an entirely different
view of his assets they didn't trust
them they looked at them as highly
illiquid that if he ran into difficulty
paying off his debt these wouldn't
necessarily be easily sold and so he
refused his request for a 50 million
dollar loan and they ultimately loaned
him 10 million they wanted to be
associated with his celebrity and they
ultimately lived to regret that decision
two years later they wrote down the loan
in total he didn't pay a dime back and
it's been well known ever since the
early 90s that US banks generally have
not touched Donald Trump he was viewed
as toxic he had a very bad credit
reputation in the US banks let me stress
that's not a political statement but it
is a statement about credit while the
Fed is once again over here de creme
zero rates of interest in the real
economy interest rates float up and down
as though the Fed doesn't exist
and again that's a hugely positive
statement about the US and global
economy that I would add if the Fed were
a fraction of as powerful as is commonly
assumed we wouldn't be the richest
nation on earth it's the fact that the
feds just not that consequential this is
a signal that we're an incredibly rich
nation it just doesn't influence the
flow of credit nearly as much as people
think only among academics and
economists untouched by reality and
untouched by the real world is there
such thing as easy credit
in the real economy its prices set by
market forces and that's a very positive
thing and so the question in the book
becomes do we need a Federal Reserve do
we need a central bank as you can
probably guess my take is that we don't
need one my argument is that if the Fed
were shut down tomorrow
few would notice the Fed began a hundred
years ago and a little over a hundred
years ago in 1913 as a lender of last
resort to solvent banks if you were a
very well-run bank with excellent assets
on your books and you ran into a
near-term cash crunch the Fed existed as
a source of a loan just to tide you over
until some of the cash came back in but
as we've seen over the last 100 plus
years it's unheard of for a solvent bank
to go to the Fed for a loan to do so is
an admission of bankruptcy and that's
the case because there are myriad non
fed sources of credit always willing to
lend to a well-run bank and so what this
is meant for the banking system overall
is that the Fed has existed to weaken it
because the Fed has become a lender of
last resort to insolvent banks that did
not rate alone in the real economy
imagine that in Silicon Valley if there
is always a central authority that could
bail out your weakest companies that
means that Webvan fred's prinster the
globe.com and itõs would still just
Silicon Valley would be a very run-down
kind of impoverished place its wealth as
a function of the fact that it's bad
businesses regularly die the Fed has
weakened the banking system by virtue of
it propping up over the years the
weakest at the expense of the most
successful banks the Fed is also a bank
regulator now my argument and this will
offend a few is that what a what a
laughable presumption if you're working
at the Fed that's usually a signal you
couldn't get a job at a bank in the
first place
and you're asking those of lesser talent
to police those who have much more
talent but I would add that with
regulators and regulations we're asking
the impossible of them we're asking
something of them that even the smartest
bankers in the world could not do we're
asking them to see into the future to
detect detect trouble spots within banks
well before problems arise well if they
could do that they'd be earning billions
in the private sector they would quite
literally be the richest investors in
the world is even the smartest investors
in the world fully admit that majority
of the time they relate to a problem so
the regulation we're asking the
impossible meaning it's very expensive
but it achieves less than nothing just
weakens the banking system even more
then of course the feds famously targets
the rate at which banks lend to one
another overnight the Fed Funds rate but
interest rates a price like any other
you know need the Federal Reserve for
that banks could easily set that price
and do on their own the Fed targets it
doesn't set anything and so again my
argument is we should end what serves no
useful purpose if we ended the Fed P you
would notice but I fully accept that my
view is a bit on the outside if you talk
to most economists they would say Oh
Mike we could think the economy quite
simply couldn't function without a
central bank what are you talking about
we would be in a non-stop depression
mode if not for the Federal Reserve
don't you know and I point out that john
d rockefeller became the richest man in
the world before the Fed but they it's
constantly rejected the very idea that I
would say we don't need a central bank
but and so that the arguments are many
the Keynesian school of economics makes
the broad point about the Fed that we
need it to increase credit in the
economy during recessionary periods to
basically prop up an economy that's
weakening her that's in freefall now
this theory fails in two very important
ways for one it can't be forgotten the
recessions are incredibly healthy as
agonizing as they are as dispiriting as
much as they kill or morale in the near
term
recessions are the amazingly bullish
signal of the massive economic boom on
the way simply because recession signal
and economy cleansing itself of all the
misuses of labor of all the bad habits
all the bad investments and all the
lousy companies that we're holding the
economy down in the first place and so
in recessions take hold that's the exact
time when you want government to do less
than nothing simply because recessions
if left alone signal the boom on the way
and so you don't want a central bank
acting in trying to allocate credit that
means the private sector has less credit
to allocate and it means bad companies
are being propped up at the expense of
what would be much greater future growth
the other problem with the Keynesian
theory gets back to something more basic
the Fed has no credit to increase again
it doesn't have some private stash of
resources around the country that it can
release into the economy the Fed can
only increase credit insofar as market
disciplined actors in the real economy
have less to increase and so as a rule
when the Fed or any central bank acts
aggressively to fight or recession in
fact what it's doing is fighting the
recovery simply because it's
instantaneously miss allocating
resources that would otherwise be pushed
to a higher use usually miss allocating
to what's already failed the economy's
broad detriment
now the monetarist school of economics
has a very different view and in
fairness to its somewhat of a more
limited view of what the Federal Reserve
should do monetarists argue that the Fed
should control the money supply that it
should oversee a set increase in the
supply of dollars in a circulation on an
annual basis the late Milton Friedman
the Nobel pre-market ear extraordinaire
is most associated with this view my
comment in the book is that this is an
example of Milton Friedman explicitly
promoting central planning and the
reason for that is basic money supplies
never a problem where there's
productivity
to paraphrase ludwig von mises
once again no nation or individual need
ever worry about having too much too
little money where there's enormous
amounts of productivity money and credit
are everywhere where there's very little
productivity money and credit are always
in everywhere scares to get into
specifics Beverly Hills never has a
money supply problem Greenwich
Connecticut never has a money supply
problem the Fed couldn't keep money
supply and credit off of the island of
Manhattan on its very best day there are
too many productive people there such as
there a magnet for credit and the money
that's used to attain that credit but
let's let's imagine a city that's
suffering economic problems right now a
poorer city so you like Baltimore in
Maryland let's imagine if the Fed
because the Fed believes it can
stimulate economic growth with its
monetary policies let's imagine that the
Fed decides to stimulate Baltimore and
it proceeds to buy up Treasuries from
Baltimore banks to increase loanable
funds and the banks there such a
scenario would fail between breakfast
and lunch and it would simply because
banks can't long stay in business
lending to individuals and businesses
who lack the means to pay the money's
borrowed back and so any increase in the
supply of dollar credit in Baltimore
would instantaneously leave Baltimore
from those banks outside the city and
probably outside of the state of
Maryland itself now in modern times
economists always look for new ways to
aggrandize themselves and add to their
importance they're always looking to
solutions when an economy it's just
individuals that if left alone would do
just fine and so the latest in the past
years economists have talked about
helicopter drops of money now by that
they're not talking literally about the
Fed dropping helicopter money into
cities but their idea is let's just
produce money on mass and people consume
that will lead to economic growth but
let's look the Fed does have an Air
Force so let's imagine a drop of
billions of dollars into the city of
Baltimore and let's imagine something
even more realistic that the
of the city would pick these billions of
dollars up and spend them right there
but let's assume that such a scenario
would failed just as much as the
increase in the supply of money in banks
and it would simply because even if they
spent every dollar in Baltimore no
business is going to expand based on a
helicopter drop so they Bank the
windfall and the money would once again
be rapidly lent out well outside of
Baltimore now people actual economists
say well John you're not an economist
you understand central bank's focus on
countries okay so let's focus on a
country several years ago when Greece
ran into economic trouble monetarists
argued that the answer is for the
European Central Bank to increase the
supply of euros and Greek banks okay but
the same scenario applies economic
inactivity in Greece did not rate
increased money and credit so any
increase in the supply of euros and
Greek banks would boomerang back to
Germany and other more economically
productive locales almost
instantaneously now let's reverse this
scenario now and think about Silicon
Valley a place that's known for enormous
wealth and productivity in this instance
the Fed believes right up to the top
that economic growth causes inflation
you've heard me say that already but
it's something that I'm passionate about
the very people who are oddly charged
with planning our economy which they
can't do but the people charge that
actually believe that more that
prosperity has a downside and so the Fed
is forever believed that it must neuter
economic growth essentially put people
out of work to slow down the economic
growth that would otherwise cause
inflation so let's imagine the Fed seen
Silicon Valley says okay we're going to
start selling bonds to Silicon Valley
banks to decrease the supply of money
there well such a scenario would fail
between lunch and dinner almost
instantaneously and it would because we
reside in a global economy
there are savers and investors around
the world desperate for exposure to the
most economically productive people on
earth so if the Fed shrinks the supply
of dollars in those banks it would be
made up instant
easily by savers around the world the
broad point here is that the Fed quite
simply cannot increase money and credit
input in locales where there's not a lot
of productivity and that are struggling
economically economically as a result
much the same in productive locales
there's no need for the Fed money and
credit sources around the world are
fighting to have exposure to it the Fed
quite simply cannot do what its critics
and its supporters say it can do all
which brings us to the Austrian school
now my book isn't is an explicit tribute
to Ludwig von Mises classic book the
theory of money and credit but despite
that in the book I'm very critical of
what I term neo or modern Austrians
modern many modern Austrians have made
the argument that the major US economic
booms of the 20th century 1920s 1980s
1990s were a creation of an easy central
bank creating excess credit and
basically putting the economy on a sugar
high they also argue that China's modern
rise was a function of an easy central
bank in China once again printing with
abandon and creating easy credit my
point in the book is this is an example
of the Austrians
embracing the very Keynesianism that
they despise that they run away from
because Austrians correctly make the
point when they talk to Keynesian scan
genes will say the one another way to
stimulate the economy is for governments
to spend with abandon and Austrians make
the correct point that no governments
can only spend insofar as they extract a
real resources from the private sector
first the negatives for the economy are
instantaneous when governments presume
to spend because politicians this is
true of Republicans or Democrats can
allocate precious resources and
disciplined fashion as the spending is
immediate in terms of its negativity for
growth well my response is how are
central bank's different why is it the
government's can't allocate politicians
can't allocate resources why do we
believe that central banks
can when central banks seek to influence
credit markets and seek to direct credit
to specific locales or countries they
instantaneously injured the economy
because once again resources are being
allocated in non-economic fashion
there's not even a near-term boom from
central bank machination x' as a rule
when they act there's less resources for
the private sector to allocate in terms
of excess credit there's quite simply no
such thing once again when you borrow
money you're borrowing resources trucks
tractors computers the Fed cannot
multiply them it can't release them in
excess that's what we create Nick in the
real economy but getting back to my
examples from Hollywood Silicon Valley
investment banking Donald Trump what we
find and this is a happy story is that
the feds just not that influential
despite all of its efforts to make
credit easy in the real economy the
price of credit floats at rates that
reflect reality and again that's a very
positive statement the feds just not
that important it staggers me that we
give it so much attention its influence
over the economy is just not that great
now the response I get to all this is
one is something about quantitative
easing what I usually get from people is
they'll say ok
interesting theory you have here but
what about quantitative easing from 20
2008 until 2014 the Fed oversaw a major
program that not only stimulated the US
economy but also stimulated a major
stock market boom they say what's your
answer to that and I say my answer is
you need to check your assumptions
because what you believe is bolide by
basic common sense now about
quantitative easing let's talk about
what that is economically first that was
the Fed borrowing 4 trillion from banks
and proceeding to buy up US Treasuries
with an eye on influencing long rates of
interest downward and also buying up
mortgages to stimulate the housing
market so let's get one thing out of the
way right here
quantitative easing had nothing to do
with economic
growth as a rule it weakened the economy
and that's the case because governments
once again can't spend us to prosperity
they can only miss allocate the wealth
we've already created as for housing it
is not a driver of economic activity
when you buy a house your purchase of a
house doesn't make you more productive
it doesn't open up foreign markets for
you it doesn't lead to cancer here's the
elongate life it doesn't lead to
software innovations that make us more
productive it doesn't expand time
housing is consumption that reduces the
amount of capital available for
entrepreneurs and businesses to expand
and securely on its face was an economic
depressant not a driver of growth at
which point to believe that it
stimulated the stock market boom you
have to believe that the deepest markets
in the world that is the US markets
populated by the most sophisticated
investors in the world were tricked by
something so plainly and nimma chol to
economic growth I think the very idea
offends what we're all about the idea
that these guys could trick the smartest
markets in the world let's be serious
but I get all the responses and one of
my favorite ones came from an economist
in Austin Texas he said oh no no no
Johnny you're not an economist so you
don't understand the Fed and conducted
an quantitative easing signaled to
investors that we've got your back that
if you buy equities will protect you
we'll keep those markets propped up and
that's what caused the stock market
rally and he added I learned this from a
Nobel laureate economist and I said okay
Lacey great point but if what you say is
true can you explain to me Japan because
he Japan's central bank has voiced at no
lever no less than eleven qyz on its
economy since the early 1990s with no
corresponding stock market rally our
Janet Yellen and Ben Bernanke utterly
competent in ways that you know Japan's
central bankers don't have a clue and
the response you get
that as well but Jhansi you don't
understand what the Fed did was push
down interest for the the QE pushed down
interest rates across in the in the u.s.
such that people had to get into
equities because that was the only place
where they could get any kind of
reasonable yield I say okay that's again
a really interesting theory except I
hope you'll explain to me Japan once
again because it's had lower interest
rates across the yield curve for decades
but its stock market is still half of
what it was in 1989 and I say also why
didn't the stocks rally in 2000 2001
when the Fed was aggressively pushing
down rates yet stocks went into freefall
did it not work there was Alan Greenspan
maybe not as as skillful as a Ben
Bernanke and they they kind of dissemble
and they say well yeah but see John you
don't understand see what actually
happened is the Fed in conducting
quantitative easing drove down yields on
bond so much but equities became the
only game in town people had rotated out
of these low yielding bonds into
equities and I say okay again a very
interesting theory but if what you say
is true there would have been a massive
correction in bonds from 2008 to 2014
that would have reflected this rotation
out of low yielding bonds and equities
but that never occurred the only major
correction and bonds occurred after
Donald Trump was elected I don't see
your argument please explain they say
well yeah but see you're not getting it
the Fed created four trillion dollars
that had to find its way into the stock
market and it had nowhere to go but this
stock market I said well didn't really
create four trillion but if you want to
believe that that's fine but for four
trillion to enter the stock market by
definition four trillion must exit in
this netherworld inhabited by economists
and academics there are only buyers but
in the real world for a buyer to express
optimism a seller must be able to
express an equal amount of pessimism for
a QE excited optimist to express that
view in the stock market as a rule a QE
skeptic must get to express an equal
amount of pessimism in markets they are
always never populated buyers and buy
buyers
sellers for for a bowl to be optimistic
in the market a bear must express an
equal amount of pessimism these things
equal each other out at which point we
get to the basic truth about markets
themselves they quite simply do not
price in the present they always price
in the future well the feds official
program of quantitative easing ended in
2014 but a telegraphed its end as early
as 2011 so if in fact QE had been the
driver of this stock market rally logic
dictates that stocks would have
corrected and corrected for good long
before 2014 to reflect the feds eventual
end of the program but in fact stocks
have continued to reach new highs
there's quite simply no evidence despite
what we're told that the Fed created a
stock market rally but there are lots of
people who believe that most economists
will tell you that most of cons will say
he's not what he doesn't know what he's
talking about you can read Morgan
Stanley's Russia Sharma he regularly
puts op-eds into the Wall Street Journal
saying oh no we on Wall Street realized
this stock market boom was just a
creation of the Fed and so you're
welcome to that point of view I fully
agree that I am on the outside on this
making a different argument but if you
believe that if you believe the Fed
despite all evidence and logic was the
source of a major stock market rally
over these last several years what you
must then acknowledge is that in
creating the stock market rally the Fed
robbed us of one that would have been
quite a bit greater and the reason for
that is fairly basic recessions are once
again healthy they signal an economy
cleansing itself of what doesn't work
economy's gained strength from their
weakness in much the same way stock
markets gain strength from their
weakness it's when markets correct that
precious resources are redirected away
from poorly run businesses to better run
one so if in fact the Fed was the source
of the
it kept precious resources and lousy
marginal companies that they expensive
much better ones thus robbing us of a
much healthier and higher stock market
and so again that's the purpose of my
book my book is to unmask the Fed is not
that important as not that consequential
I say and what is an offense to common
sense just because we don't need the Fed
but I have no illusions the Fed will
never be ended no politician no
president no Congress will ever end the
Fed rest assured that's the bad news for
those who want and over with here's the
good news market forces are ending the
Fed for us the channel through which the
Fed presumes to influence the economy is
the banking system the US banking system
presently represents 15% of total credit
in the economy that numbers and freefall
and it is because banks are being
suffocated before our eyes by the same
federal government to save them and that
number is going to drop with the decline
of banks so declines the feds power
market forces are ending the Fed for us
we don't need Congress to do it and I'll
leave it there thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't have a lot of time for
questions and for that I apologize I got
wrapped up and what do you say please
join me again in thanking John upon
exiting this venue our wonderful
volunteers will enthusiastically accept
your donation to the Savannah Book
Festival it is because of your
generosity that we're able to keep it
free so thank you so much for coming and
forgive me for no questions
[Applause]
[Music]
you're all convinced
ah
yes
not everything
they took your questions
trust me my choice
continuing to
and and the other basics training me if
it's harmless our common
and that
regulations
when Congress armhole
[Music]
all that
[Music]
Oh
not for you
better